Nos pide que resolvamos, el valor absoluto
de 3x menos 9 esto es igual a 0
y que grafiquemos la solución en una recta numérica.
Y lo primero que quiero hacer es copiar de
nuevo la ecuación con valor absoluto.
Y me queda que el valor absoluto de "3x" menos
9 esto es igual a 0.
Y bueno, date cuenta que la única solución
de esta ecuación con valor absoluto
es que "3x" menos 9 sea igual a 0, si yo tengo que
el valor absoluto de algo es igual a 0,
ese algo tiene que ser forzosamente 0.
Recuerda que el valor absoluto, lo podíamos
ver como la distancia que había al 0,
y si yo tengo que la distancia que hay del 0 es
igual a 0, pues no me moví, es decir, que
me quedo en el 0 ó dicho de otra manera,
lo podríamos pensar también como esto,
si yo me tomo el valor absoluto de algún número
y esto es igual a 0, no queda de otra,
este número tiene que ser igual a 0, porque imagínate,
si yo tuviera el valor absoluto de algo igual a 1,
pues hay de dos sopas, pues que este
algo sea igual a 1 o que sea igual a -1,
pero aquí en este caso, tendríamos que este algo
o es 0 ó es igual a -0, pero 0 y -0 es lo mismo,
por lo tanto no queda de otra,
"3x" menos 9 es igual a 0.
Así que date cuenta que el paso más importante
de todo este ejercicio ya lo hicimos,
que es darnos cuenta que lo que está adentro del valor absoluto tendrá que ser igual a 0.
Y como lo que está adentro del valor absoluto
es igual a 0, entonces "3x" menos 9
es lo que tiene que ser igual a 0.
Espero que hasta aquí vayamos en orden.
Y bueno, para resolver esta ecuación lo que
hay que hacer, primero sumar 9 de ambos lados
de la ecuación, así que voy a sumar 9 y
voy a sumar 9 y ¿qué me queda?
"3x" menos 9 más 9, pues -9 y 9 se van y
me queda simple y sencillamente, "3x",
esto del lado izquierdo, mientras que del lado
derecho me queda, 0 más 9, 0 más 9 es 9.
Y bueno, si yo quiero despejar a "x", lo único que hay que hacer es pasar este 3 del otro lado,
con su operación contraria, o dicho
de otra manera, lo que voy a hacer es dividir
ambos lado de la ecuación entre 3, para que
así se pueda cancelar este 3.
Me queda "3x" entre 3, pues esto es "1x",
que es lo mismo que "x"
y del otro lado me queda 9 entre 3, lo cual es 3.
Es decir, que "x" igual a 3 es la solución
de esta ecuación con valor absoluto,
de la ecuación el valor absoluto de
"3x" menos 9 es igual a 0,
que de hecho sería bastante bueno que lo corroboráramos.
Como en el video pasado ya hicimos la gráfica,
vamos a hacer la comprobación de que en efecto
nos dé 0, así que vamos a ver.
El valor absoluto de 3 por 3, porque recuerda
que "x" es igual a 3, entonces me quedaría,
el valor absoluto de 3 por 3 menos 9, esto
tiene que ser igual a 0, pero 3 por 3 es 9,
9 menos 9, en valor absoluto tiene que ser igual a 0,
pero 9 menos 9 es 0 y el valor absoluto de 0 es 0.
Por lo tanto, "x" igual a 3 es la solución
de esta ecuación con valor absoluto.